Speaker 1: Kyle Rittenhouse We knew that
Rittenhouse was going to be lionized and made
Speaker 2: into a hero after he was
Speaker 1: acquitted in the killing of two people
and shooting of a third in Kenosha, Wisconsin.
Speaker 2: And it is happening exactly
as predicted.
Speaker 1: Some of you Republicans who
watch wrote to me and they said, David, and you
said, David, you know, the verdict was the right
one. But nobody's going to make a hero out of this
kid because ultimately what happened is a tragedy.
And I said, No, no, no, no. They're going to
make a hero out of this kid, and it's happening.
First, he got his media around, so he got to
meet Donald Trump. He was interviewed by Tucker
Carlson. He was invited here. He was invited
there everywhere. At the end of the day. Even
if you believe that what Kyle Rittenhouse did was
legally justifiable as self-defense, which many
people on the left do, and I said the way the
Speaker 2: laws are written and based on the
evidence not guilty is the quote correct verdict
Speaker 1: because it is totally plausible that
he feared for his life in a situation he never
should have been in. Into which he placed himself,
Speaker 2: I said not guilty is
Speaker 1: what follows the way the law is
written. But what he did was still horrible.
Speaker 2: It's nothing to celebrate
here. It was a
Speaker 1: failure of
Speaker 2: parenting. It was a
Speaker 2: gun culture. It was a failure
Speaker 1: of militia, culture,
vigilante culture. All of these horrible things
that plague the United States. There's nothing
to celebrate here. But now Kyle Rittenhouse
is quite literally being held up as a hero
whose actions should be celebrated.
Speaker 2: And the latest
installment is this speakership.
Speaker 1: He's going to be a speaker
at this completely outrageous
Speaker 2: event held by
Speaker 1: right wing group Turning
Point USA called America Fest 2021
in Phenix, Arizona. I will just miss it.
I've been in Arizona the last two weeks.
I leave Friday. The event is Saturday
really a shame, huh? And the question I
have is what is there for him to speak about,
like how to kill people and get away with it?
It's beyond sickening. And again, even if you
think he is legally not guilty as he was found,
what is there to celebrate here? What is there to
Speaker 2: learn from him other than you two
Speaker 1: could insert yourself into
a situation you have no business in
and get away with killing two people?
Speaker 2: Like,
is that the lesson from Kyle Rittenhouse?
Speaker 1: His story? There is nothing here
other than a cult of personality, and disgustingly
they are celebrating it. And in so doing, they are
celebrating the killings. There's really no way
around it because there's no other substance.
Speaker 2: There's nothing
Speaker 1: there. And the
problem, there's a number of problems with this,
but one of the questions that comes up is if we
celebrate the fact that a 17 year old did this,
what about a 16 year old? What about a 15 year
old? What about a 12 year old with good trigger
Speaker 2: discipline, as they love to say,
Speaker 1: like, where is the end with this?
Maybe I'm wrong, and he'll show up and talk about
Speaker 2: how he's looking
Speaker 1: forward to a career
Speaker 2: in nursing.
Speaker 1: As we often heard during
the trial. But somehow, I don't. I
don't think so, and I genuinely don't
Speaker 2: understand what on earth
Speaker 1: you would.
Speaker 2: You would speak
like. What's his open? What is the body
Speaker 1: of his speech? And I can only
imagine that he's getting paid for this. If you
can imagine that, although maybe not the one thing
Speaker 2: that makes me think, maybe not.
Speaker 1: As I was invited on to Charlie
Kirk's show a little while ago, Traveled didn't
work out, and they actually had the gall to say,
We're a nonprofit so we don't pay anybody for
appearances and speaking and all that stuff.
I don't know if they tell Kyle Rittenhouse the
same thing. Maybe he he probably has a different
status within Turning Point USA than I do. But
they actually for for me and a few others I know,
they said, now we're a nonprofit, we're
Speaker 2: nonprofit,
so we can't pay you to appear.
Speaker 1: So Kyle Rittenhouse
being made exactly out to be the
hero that we predicted they would.
How long does this grift run?
Speaker 2: I actually don't think it
Speaker 1: runs that long. I think it's like
a couple of years, but maybe it's something
that he can use to keep the Great Gravy
Train coming for a long period of time.